donc je suis la dernière je vous
félicite de porc est tombé endormi c'est
quand même vendredi soir dont je vous
invite tous à prendre une grande
respiration
collective
c'est aussi pour moi au fait
alors
23 février 2020 meurtre d'amar or bruit
par des racistes parce qu'il était noir
et par ci faisait du jogging
13 mars 2020 maire depuis hannah tyler
par la police pendant qu'elle dormait
25me 2020 maire de judge floyd par la
police pendant une mise en arrêt
28 septembre 2020
meurtre de joyce et jake one aux mains
de notre système de santé
toutes ces morts que j'ai ce que je
viens de nommer ont toutes été
enregistrées
d'une façon ou d'une autre de sorte que
en quelque sorte nous avons tous été
témoins de cela
maintenant vous voyez moi j'ai deux
enfants
une petite fille de 4 ans et un petit
garçon de deux ans et demi
par la beauté de la génétique
ma fille a une couleur de peau assez
pâle pas mal comme moi mon garçon lui à
la peau un petit peu plus foncée
bien sûr ils sont super mignon je suis
très objective là dedans bien entendu
avec leurs petites boucles et puis le
grand sourire et puis leur énergie
insatiable entre autres choses
mais il ya un fait qui demeure le fait
que mon fils va naviguer la société de
façon complètement différente que ma
fille parce que d'ici une dizaine
d'années il va grandir il va grandir
pour devenir un grand homme un grand
homme noir comme ceux que je viens de
nommer à qui on a enlevé la vie sur une
base arbitraire qui est la couleur de
leur peau et la perception qu'il celle
ci a pour certains et certaines
quand on me demande pourquoi je fais
qu'est ce que je fais je donne toujours
deux raisons la première ben j'aime ce
que je fais ce serait dommage sinon et
puis j'aime l'humanité avec un grand h
la deuxième est ma famille qui dans
toute sa beauté sa splendeur ses nuances
est en fait une cible dans la société
dans laquelle on vit actuellement
comme ceci m'amène à une question quand
même assez importante à ce point ci de
notre relation notre interaction c'est
ben qu'est ce que je fais qu'est ce que
je suis
alors je m'appelle julie savaria mais
prenons sont elles et elles je me
présente comme étant une femme si ce
genre sénégal aux canadiennes je suis
une entrepreneure je suis aussi une
spécialiste jedi
jedi
donc je suis pas mal certain que vous
connaissez quand même les acronymes ed i
d i d i donc équité diversité inclusion
diversité quitté inclusion diversité et
l'inclusion et cetera mais qu en est-il
de jedi
bien entendu je parle pas de star wars
même si vous pouvez toujours imaginer
comme étant une guerrière avec un sabre
de lumière et de connaissances battant
contre l'injustice et l'iniquité de ce
monde
mais l'acronyme jedi en tant que tel en
fait c'est justice équité diversité et
l'inclusion
vous avez sûrement aussi tous une notion
de caisse que chaque mot dans l'acronyme
veut dire mais juste que vous puissiez
avoir une vue d'ensemble de caisse que
le concept veut dire juste revenir
brièvement sur les définitions de chaque
mot mais je le faire à l'envers et je
vous expliquer pourquoi après
donc le i pour inclusion donc sentiment
d'appartenance sentiment qu'on a sa
place qu'on les respecte et qu'on ait vu
qu'on est valorisée l'aider pour
diversité petit clin d'oeil à ma
collègue la présence indéniable de
différence de toutes sortes et l'on
parle différences culturelles de
différences démographiques des
différences cognitives de neuro
diversité et j'en passe
le e pourrait quitter qui est le fait de
donner à tout le monde tout ce dont ils
ou elles ont besoin afin d'accomplir
leurs objectifs ou d'atteindre les mêmes
résultats peu importe leur situation de
départ
et finalement on a le fameux j appelle
julie certes mais logis pour justice
justice un monde où toutes les
discriminations les barrières
systémiques ont été éliminés est ce un
monde où tout le monde peut juste être
juste être à leur plein potentiel
temps peut-être que là vous êtes dit me
suis dit là tu viens de décrire idev pas
jedi
tout à fait mais j'aimerais vous poser
en même temps une question
le fait est que souvent quand on va
parler de ce sujet on va penser à
diversité en premier lieu c'est toujours
comme ça où il faut plus de diversité la
diversité
je suis pas d'accord en fait on devrait
plutôt penser à inclusion avant toute
chose
parce que
comment est ce qu'on veut qu'une plante
puisse grossir produire des produits des
fleurs accomplir ses objectifs si elle
n'a pas un seul qui est propice à sa
croissance qui peut lui donner les
ressources nécessaires pour qu'elle
puisse accomplir ce but c'est la même
chose si on n'a pas d'inclusion
la diversité ne va pas suivre
et c'est pour ça que je présente
habituellement le conseil jedi à
l'envers mais ensuite pourquoi ce que
j'utilise le terme jedi en tant que tel
et bien c'est parce qu'en prenant le
terme jedi bas ça me donne une vue plus
globale une vision beaucoup plus grande
une vision qui m'inspire de qu'est ce
que je veux faire qu'est-ce que je peux
faire qu'on s'entend aussi y déj jedi le
choix quand même vite fait
spécialiste idev
ça sonne moins bien que spécialiste je
dors et déjà
et
l'inclusion c'est un comportement c'est
une façon d'être la diversité ça devrait
être un fait
l'équité ça doit être un but un objectif
mais une fois qu'on atteint l'objectif
peint par l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé
qu'est ce qu'on fait on passe à notre
objectif ou bien on se pousse pour aller
un petit peu plus loin et c'est là que
le gie de justice vient prendre toute sa
beauté c'est d'aller un petit peu plus
loin au delà de l'équité la diversité et
l'inclusion
donc vous pouvez me dire ok mais
pourquoi c'est important alors d'être un
ou une jedi pourquoi est-ce qu'on
devrait infuser un peu plus ce jedi dans
notre vie
il ya plusieurs raisons pour cela
le contexte social des dernières années
la pandémie nous ont vraiment forcer à
être témoin et à absorber la douleur des
communautés autochtones des communautés
noires des communautés asiatiques des
communautés trans et j'en passe mais
pourquoi maintenant parce que je veux
dire ça fait des décennies qu'il ya des
injustices
mais en fait j'en reviens petit pas
qu'est ce que ma collègue a mentionné
tout à l'heure c'est que on est à un
point un moment de notre histoire où est
ce que notre monde et notre société n'a
jamais été aussi mature et aptes à
pouvoir reconnaître l'intensité des
émotions qui se cache derrière le
concept jedi mais aussi derrière le
racisme la discrimination
l'injustice et l'iniquité
de la même façon que quand il ya eu
l'attentât du 11 septembre
je sais pas si je suis trop vieille pour
ça ça vaut coup tout le monde presque
tout le monde à qui on va parler vont se
rappeler d'où est-ce qu'ils étaient
qu'est ce qu'il faisait et bien moi
c'est la même chose pour quand le
verdict pour les meurtriers de mon abri
et de georges claude est tombé je me
rappelle d'où est-ce que j'étais qu'est
ce que je faisais j'étais à la maison
et aussi j'étais en train d'aller
chercher mes enfants à la garderie
en même temps c'est respectivement mais
dans les deux cas je me suis arrêté
et j'ai pleuré
j'ai pleuré des larmes de joie et de
soulagement parce que enfin j'avais un
aperçu d'un monde où est-ce que juste
avaient été rendus et où est ce que des
personnes comme mon fils n'aurait pas
juste à survivre mais pourrait vraiment
vivre
dans notre position en tant que membre
d'un groupe 2001 ou d'un groupe non
dominante selon la société va grandement
dictée l'attention qu'on va porter à
certains sujets et aussi que s'il va
venir nous toucher dans notre coeur de
façon viscérale
en parlant des motions d'ailleurs
on a tendance à oublier à quel point
chaque mot a une charge émotive assez
intense
donc outre les définitions des mots dont
diversité racisme discrimination ou bien
chien un burger etc chaque mot va voir
sa charge émotive et si on se concentre
cette charge émotive l'on se rend compte
qu'on va pouvoir avoir accès à toute une
gamme d'émotions ça peut être de la joie
de la surprise ou bien de la honte de la
souffrance de l'oppression personne
n'aime ressentir de la souffrance ou de
l'oppression ça c'est sûr mais le fait
est que les émotions sont des messages
et extrêmement puissants
surtout dans un contexte d'équité et de
justice
il faut au contraire pouvoir les
reconnaître pour voir les accepter
passons des associations des engins de
changements et on ne peut pas parler de
choses jedi ou de toute chose équité peu
importe sans parler et ressentir des
émotions
de la même façon que l'on peut pas
vraiment parler et pratiques et des
pratiques anti racistes et
discriminatoires sans penser au contexte
un petit peu plus large et là je ne
parle pas de diluer le racisme la
discrimination et cetera dans une vague
de djeddah et c'est pas ça que je dis au
contraire moi ce que j'ai dit c'est
qu'on devrait plutôt ajouter des cordes
antiracisme
discrimination lgbt qu par exemple à
notre arc jedi
adopter une mentalité de jedi ça nous
permet d'être plus confiant qu'est ce
qui se passe autour de nous adoptez une
mentalité de jedi ça nous permet aussi
d'être plus aptes à pouvoir voir les
similitudes mais aussi les différences
des gens autour de nous qu'elle soit
évidente comme la couleur de la peau ou
l'apparence physique ou bien peu plus
nuancées comme la relation à l'autorité
la façon de résoudre des conflits la
façon d'innover de trouver des solutions
avoir une mentalité de jedi pas nous
outiller afin d'avoir ces conversations
dont on a tant besoin pour faire avancer
notre monde donc il nous faut aussi ses
émotions
quand je pense d'eux l'avait peut-être
compris il faut passer outre le cadre
proscrit de l'équité la diversité et
l'inclusion nous sommes présentement
dans un continuum d'apprentissage de
co-création ou est ce qu'on ne doit
absolument pas se limiter parce que les
interactions la dynamique humaine n'est
pas limité en soi bien au contraire on
est dans un cycle de régénération et
d'adaptation constante donc six ans rêve
dans ce cadre bien illimité bien
popularisé mien proscrit d'équité
diversité et l'inclusion on va pouvoir
trouver des solutions certes mais des
solutions qui vont être limités en
nature et qui risque même de générer
plus d'iniquité donc pourquoi pas sortir
de la boîte et crée des solutions qui
vont vraiment pouvoir incarner un peu
plus de justice comme on le souhaite
quand je dis pourquoi c'est important
d'être à ou une jedi peut-être un petit
peu biaisé ici mais je pensais quand
même important mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut faire qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
certes il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on
puisse faire mais je vais vous laisser
avec trois choses que vous pouvez faire
dès maintenant pour devenir un ou une
jedi ou juste être un petit peu plus
j'adore
la première chose
continuez à vous éduquer et moi je me
mets là dedans aussi parce que comme
j'ai dit à l'heure
nous sommes pas en continuant
d'apprentissage et moi je n'arrête
jamais d'apprendre donc continuons à
nous éduquer afin d'être plus simple et
plus intelligente matière de
discrimination d'injustice de racisme et
toute chose j'adore et pour cela il faut
vraiment qu'on puisse apprendre à
réfléchir à notre place à notre rôle
dans ce sujet mais aussi à notre rôle
potentiel en tant qu oppresseurs en tant
que victime en tant que micro agresseurs
ou en tant qu'allié
il faut être prêt être en mesure
d'entrer dans un processus de des
apprentissages je sais vous êtes au
cégep de d apprendre que vous avez
appris pour mieux réapprendre après
et ça ça va demander aussi une certaine
connaissance de soi une certaine
conscience de soi un petit peu d'auto
régulation aussi mais sans pour autant
tomber dans l'autocensure de ce qu'on
ressent de ce qu'on vit donc le
changement va commencer d'abord au
niveau individuel pour pouvoir avoir des
répercussions au niveau institutionnel
et ensuite au niveau sociétal et
systémique
la deuxième chose
le fait d'apprendre
lire des articles qui écouter des
podcasts
suivre des formations écouter ou
regarder des têtes toc par exemple ça
c'est une chose mais il faut absolument
pratiquer qu'est ce qu'on apprend sinon
ça devient juste une accumulation de
connaissances dans un coin de notre
cerveau qui prend la poussière
par exemple à l'école secondaire
j'adorerais tout ce qui était
trigonométrie suite numérique fonction
algèbre j'adorais ça
mais si on me met maintenant une suite
numérique devant les yeux j'aurais
absolument aucune idée coiffeur c'est
normal parce que je me suis pas pratiqué
je n'ai pas pratiqué la connaissance
dont c'est la même chose avec tous les
concepts djeddah à les compter les cons
le contexte anti racisme discrimination
etc
si on ne prend pas le temps d'exercer ce
muscle jedi 2
le faire grossir de lui faire prendre du
volume à ce moment là il sera pas prêt
qu'on en aura besoin
donc c'est important de porter attention
à ça et surtout de donner un sens aux
expériences dans lesquels on va être
pour pouvoir développer faire avancer
notre cheminement en équité diversité
inclusion et justice
et finalement
troisième point
il est jamais trop tard pour devenir un
jedi
vous apprends rien il n'est jamais trop
tard pour apprendre et ça on peut
commencer à un très jeune âge il ya
vraiment pas d'âge tout est adapté tout
va dépendre du vocabulaire et puis du
détail dans lequel on veut aller mais la
même façon que je parlais qu'il fallait
s'éduquer et ceux pratiqués il faut
aussi pouvoir montrer l'exemple aux gens
autour de nous que ce soit des
générations passées où des générations
futures
il faut pouvoir
en fait défense qui est juste
pour pouvoir aussi avoir peut-être un
aperçu même si c'est d'une seconde de
quoi peut avoir l'air un monde où le
concept jedi est vraiment incarné oups
il ya d'accord donc pour finir
être un jedi qu'on y pense c'est un
droit d'humanité
la justice l'équité la diversité
l'inclusion sont tout d'abord et avant
tout une conversation humaine et même
plus c'est une pratique humaine qui
devrait être un briquet dans le tissu
humain de notre société de nos systèmes
sont des conversations et des pratiques
courageuse car ça prend du courage pour
être et vivre hors des attentes de notre
société de nos systèmes modernes
donc je vous invite à continuer à
humaniser le concept jedi afin de
pouvoir ré humaniser notre monde moderne
pour les générations passées donc nos
ancêtres les générations actuelles les
générations futures pour ma fille pour
monfils
pour tous tout chacun et chacune
soyez tous et toutes des jedi merci
[Applaudissements]